and Far Away lands slaves dig the Earth
for beautiful gems called quartz which
contain silicon dioxide Alchemist or
chemical engineers then refine and cook
them into silicon substrate a material
that can be doped to act as both a
conductor and insulator shamans also
known as electrical engineers and
inscribe billions of microscopic symbols
on them that can't be seen with a naked
eye when lightning passes through them
they can speak the incomprehensible
language of binary highly trained
Wizards called software Engineers can
learn this language to build powerful
machines that create Illusions these
Illusions can then control the way
people think and act in the real world
in today's illusion I will harness this
magic to pull back the veil on the
almighty computer by looking at four
different ways computers actually
compute things at the hardware level
because to put a computer needs a pu
like a CPU GPU TPU or dpu the last 100
years have been crazy the first truly
programmable computer was the Z1 which
was created by Conrad Zeus in 1936 in
his mom's basement but then it got blown
up in 1943 during the bombardment of
Berlin its entire highly mechanical with
over twenty thousand Parts it represents
binary data with sliding metal sheets it
could do things like Boolean algebra and
floating Point numbers and had a clock
rate of 1 Hertz which means it could
execute one instruction per second to
put that in perspective modern CPUs are
measured in gigahertz or billions of
cycles per second over the next 10 years
people thought really hard about how
computers should actually work and in
1945 we got the Von Neumann architecture
which is still used in modern ships
today it's the foundational design that
describes how data and instructions are
stored in the same memory space then
handled by a processing unit a couple
years later there is a huge breakthrough
with the invention of the transistor
which is a semiconductor that can
amplify or switch electrical signals
like a transistor could represent a one
if current passes through it or a zero
if current doesn't pass through it this
was a hugely forward then in 1958 the
integrated circuit was developed
allowing multiple transistors to be
placed on a single silicon chip then
finally in 1971 Intel released the first
commercially available microprocessor
that had all the features you know and
love from a modern CPU it was a 4-bit
processor meaning it could handle four
bits of data at a time with
approximately 2300 transistors the clock
speed was 740 kilohertz which was
extremely fast at the time CPUs are
pretty complicated and if you really
want to learn how they work I'd highly
recommend reading cpu.land which does an
amazing job of breaking down how they
actually execute programs it's totally
free and was written by high schoolers
Lexi Matic and hack Club but what I want
to focus on is what they're actually
used for so we can compare them to the
other pus like its name implies the
central processing unit is like the
brain of a computer it runs the
operating system executes programs and
manages Hardware it has access to the
system's RAM and includes a hierarchy of
caches on the chip itself for faster
data retrieval a CPUs optimize for
sequential computations that require
extensive branching and logic like
imagine some navigation software that
needs to run an algorithm to compute the
shortest possible route between two
points the algorithm may have a lot of
conditional logic like if else
statements that can only be computed one
by one or sequentially acpu is optimized
for this type of work now modern CPUs
also have multiple cores which allows
them to do work in parallel which allows
you to use multiple applications on your
PC at the same time and programmers can
write code that does multi-threading to
utilize the cores on your machine to run
code in parallel check out this video on
my second Channel if you want to learn
how to do that in JavaScript now to make
a computer faster one might think we
could just add more and more CPU cores
the reality though is that CPU cores are
expensive as the cores scale up so does
power consumption and the heat
dissipation requirements it becomes a
matter of diminishing returns and the
extra complexity is just not worth it at
the time of this video 24 cores is
typically the upper limit of higher end
ships like Apple's M2 Ultra and Intel's
I9 but there are massive chips like the
128 core AMD epic designed for data
centers now when it comes to CPUs there
are multiple different architectures out
there and that's a big deal if you're
doing low-level systems programming but
every developer should be familiar with
arm and x86 64-bit x86 is what you'll
find on most modern desktop computers
while arm is what you'll find on mobile
devices because it has a more simplified
instruction set and better power
efficiency which means better battery
life however this distinction has been
changing over the last few years thanks
to the Apple silicon chips which have
proven that the arm architecture can
also work for high performance Computing
on laptops and desktops and even
Microsoft is investing in running
windows with arm in addition arm is
becoming more and more popular with
Cloud providers like the neoverse chip
or Amazon's graviton 3 which allows the
cloud to compute more stuff with less
power consumption which is one of the
biggest expenses in a data center but at
some point we've all hit the limitations
of a CPU like when I try to run pirated
Nintendo 64 games on my Raspberry Pi it
lags like crazy that's because a lot of
computation is required to calculate the
appearance of all the lights and shadows
in a game on demand well that's where
the GPU comes in a graphics Processing
Unit or graphics card is highly
optimized for parallel Computing unlike
a CPU with a measly 16 cores nvidia's
RTX 4080 has nearly 10 000 cores each
one of these cores can handle a floating
points or integer computation per cycle
and that allows games to to perform tons
of linear algebra in parallel to render
Graphics instantly every time you push a
button on your controller gpus are also
essential for training deep learning
models that perform tons of matrix
multiplication on large data sets this
has led to massive demand in the GPU
market and nvidia's stock price recently
landed on the moon so he says okay give
me 200 I gave him 200 and for 200 I
bought 15 I think it was 20 of Nvidia if
gpus have so many cores why not just use
a GPU over a CPU for everything the
short answer is that not all cores are
created equal a single CPU core is far
faster than a single GPU core and its
architecture can handle complex logic
and branching whereas a GPU is only
designed for simple computations most of
the code out in the world can take
advantage of parallel Computing and
needs to run sequentially with a single
thread a CPU is like a Toyota Camry it's
extremely versatile but can't take you
to the Moon a GPU is more like a rocket
ship it's really fast when you want to
go in a straight line but not really
ideal if we're going to pick up your
groceries as the name lies gpus were
originally designed for graphics but
nowadays everybody wants them to train
an AI that can overthrow the government
but there's actually Hardware designed
for that use case called the TPU or
tensor Processing Unit these chips are
very similar to gpus but designed
specifically for tensor operations like
the matrix multiplication required for
deep learning they were developed by
Google in 2016 to integrate directly
with its tensorflow software a TPU
contains thousands of these things
called multiply accumulators it allows
the hardware to perform matrix
multiplication without the need to
access registers or shared memory like a
GPU would and if you have a neural
network that's going to take weeks or
months to train atpu could save you
millions of dollars that's pretty cool
but that brings us to the newest type of
pu the dpu or data processing unit the
CEO of Nvidia described it as the third
major pillar of computing going forward
but you'll likely never use one in your
own computer because they're designed
specifically for Big Data Centers
they're most like a CPU and typically
based on the arm architecture but are
highly optimized for moving data around
they handle networking functions like
packet processing routing and security
and also deal with data storage like
compression and encryption the main goal
is to relieve the CPU from any data
processing jobs so it can focus on
living its best life by doing general
purpose Computing and with that we've
looked at four different ways a computer
computes but there's one more wild card
that we might get to experience in our
lifetime and that's the qpu or Quantum
Processing Unit all the chips we've
looked at so far deal in bits ones and
zeros but quantum computers deal in
qubits or Quantum bits that can exist in
a superposition of both States
simultaneously now a Cuba can represent
multiple possibilities at once but when
measured it collapses into one of the
possible States based on probability
these qubits are subject to quantum
entanglement which means the state of
one is directly related to another no
matter the distance between them these
properties are used together to create
Quantum Gates which are like logic gates
and regular computers but work in
entirely different ways that I'm too
stupid to understand what I do
understand is that if this technology
ever gets good it will completely change
the world current cryptographic systems
like RSA are underpinned by the fact
that classical algorithms used for
factorization would take billions of
years to crack with Brute Force even
with the best computers of today but
quantum computers will be able to run
different algorithms like Shore's
algorithm that's exponentially faster at
factorization and thus poses a major
threat to Modern encryption and security
luckily there's no quantum computer
today that can run this algorithm and
even if there were they sure as hell
wouldn't be telling you and me about it